sólo 11 días después de ser retomada por
el gobierno la histórica ciudad etíope
de lalibela vuelve a estar en manos de
los rebeldes según los residentes los
combatientes del frente de liberación
popular de tigre entraron en el centro
de la ciudad el domingo después de que
las fuerzas gubernamentales se marcharán
el sábado por la noche y retomaron el
control de la zona sin disparos cruzados
lalibela patrimonio mundial de la unesco
es un lugar de peregrinación para los
cristianos etíopes gracias a sus 11
iglesias rupestres monolíticas
medievales excavadas en la roca roja los
combates estallaron en etiopía hace más
de un año con la región de tigre en el
foco del conflicto desde junio los
rebeldes han retomado varias ciudades
importantes y han ampliado el conflicto
desde tigre a las regiones vecinas de
alojar y ampara cuando la capital addis
abeba pareció estar en peligro en
noviembre el primer ministro ahmed se
puso al frente de sus tropas según su
gabinete ahora está de nuevo en primera
línea por su parte las fuerzas del
gobierno han reconquistado recientemente
localidades estratégicas como la de arco
o quizá ibor en hasta el momento el
conflicto ha desplazado a más de 2
millones de personas y ha llevado a casi
9 millones al borde de la hambruna
además se han denunciado masacres y
violaciones por parte de ambos bandos
human rights watch pidió a la onu que
investigará los presuntos crímenes de
guerra cometidos